über die Europäische Union hinaus aber
wie ich eben angedeutet habe das kann
man nicht und damit Herren und wir gehen
sofort nach Moskau denn es gibt eine
Pressekonferenz des Bundeskanzlers
der lange mit Präsident Putin gesprochen
wir haben kein Thema ausgelassen die
schwierigen nicht die einfache auch
nicht die kulturellen Fragen die
wirtschaftlichen Fragen und natürlich
die vielen vielen Themen die sich um das
die Frage der europäischen Sicherheit
drehen und die Ukraine
dass wir so lange miteinander gesprochen
haben ist ein gutes Zeichen weil dabei
sich auch immer wieder
deutlicher werden lassen dass wir nicht
in allen Punkten übereinstimmen aber das
ist überall ausreichend Ansatzpunkte
dafür gibt weiter zu reden und
Verständigung zu suchen und das ist
erstmal die gute Botschaft russland hat
Wünsche geäußert die NATO und die USA
zum Beispiel haben darauf geantwortet
nur ein Teil davon ist übereinstimmt
aber es ist doch genug dafür dass man
weiterreden kann auch in dem was
Russland jetzt neuerdings gesagt hat und
auch heute noch mal betont hat dass es
Ansatzpunkte gibt und das ist auch sich
lohnt weiter zu reden nicht die gleiche
Botschaft und das ist unsere große
Pflicht die wir haben als diejenigen die
Verantwortung für unsere Staaten haben
dass wir alles dafür tun dass wir jetzt
diese Ansatzpunkte nutzen um Frieden und
Sicherheit in Europa
möglich zu machen um dafür zu sorgen
dass wir eine gute Zukunft haben und das
ein Krieg in Europa vermieden werden
kann
wir wissen nicht wie es weitergeht und
weitergehen wird aber wir können
durchaus sagen es gibt genügend
Ansatzpunkte dafür dass die Dinge eine
gute Entwicklung nehmen und diese
Ansatzpunkte müssen wir nutzen
der Bundeskanzler ist war ihre erste
Begegnung mit Präsident Putin in ihrer
Rolle als Regierungschef sie beide als
Regierungschefs wie es ihr Eindruck wie
arbeiten sie zusammen wie werden sie
zusammenarbeiten wie glauben sie wird
ihre Beziehung sein um eben solche
Situationen wie jetzt klären zu können
ist das vertrauensvoll wird das
vertrauensvoll also wie es ihr Eindruck
von Präsident Putin
ich habe schon berichtet das war ein
sehr intensives Gespräch auch ein sehr
vertrauensvolles Gespräch es ist nicht
entlang von sprechzetteln gegangen
sondern wir haben uns in die Themen
hinein vertieft und sie in alle
Richtungen hin Aart hat und ich glaube
das ist eine gute Ausgangspunkt Basis
angesichts der schwierigen
Herausforderung für den bestehen
Herr Bundeskanzler das war ja
bemerkenswerter Schlagabtausch der hatte
ja fast etwas von einem sportmatch war
das auch ich sag jetzt mal die
Temperatur des vier-augengesprächs oder
ging es da noch kraftvoller hier oder
ging es da so gut her dass man sich das
so leisten konnte und eine das war die
atmosphärische Frage und inhaltlich
Präsident Putin hat von einem Genozid im
don-bus gesprochen und er hat das was
letztlich an Signalen aus Kiew
mitgekommen gebracht wurde ja im Grunde
zurückgewiesen hat gesagt ja morgen
übermorgen da wird gemunkelt er braucht
deutlichere
deutliche Garantien können Sie da auch
noch mal was zusammen danke
wir haben uns einen freundlicher
Atmosphäre unterhalten aber natürlich
haben wir bei den Fragen wo wir
unterschiedliche Ausgangspunkte haben
die auch intensiv erörtert sie haben ein
ganz kleines Bild davon bekommen in der
Pressekonferenz aber es war immer auch
wieder über lange Passagen so dass wir
Übereinstimmung haben feststellen können
die auch die
Ausgangsbasis dafür sind dass es sich
lohnt an guten Beziehungen zu arbeiten
zwischen der Europäischen Union und
Russland zwischen der Nato und Russland
zwischen den USA und Russland und
natürlich auch ganz besonders zwischen
Deutschland und Russland dafür sind
genügend Ansatzpunkte da
eins ist ganz klar
wenn alle sagen sie stehen zu der
Minsker Vereinbarung die anderen müssen
es auch dann ist das
ein guter Anfang aber nicht genug am
Ende müssen alle zumindest der
Vereinbarung stehen und das bedeutet für
jeden dass er sich ein Ruck geben muss
denn für jeden bedeutet diese
Vereinbarung die einmal geschlossen
worden ist dass man ein bisschen anders
agieren muss als manche pressestatements
die man in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten gelesen hat und dieses Gefühl
glaube ich wächst in allen dass das
jetzt so ist es wird jetzt darauf
ankommen sich auch an das zu halten was
man von den anderen fordert für sich
selbst noch einmal Völkermord das war
eine heftiges heftiger Satz das ist ein
heftiges Wort allerdings eins das ja
wenn man die russische Presse verfolgt
jetzt nicht neu ist im Hinblick auf die
Diskussion dort
es ist aber falsch also das glaube ich
sollte man ganz klar sagen es geht hier
um eine schwierige Situation und der Weg
wie man daraus kommt ist gewiesen über
trilaterale Gespräche
mit der OSZE der Ukraine und Russland
mit den Vertretern der beiden
Verwaltungsbezirke dabei in denen über
die Vorschläge der ukrainischen
Regierung zu den anstehenden Themen
diskutiert wird und dafür müssen die auf
den Tisch dass die auf den Tisch kommen
das ist jetzt zugesagt
der Präsident hat ja heute in sehr
deutlicher Form in den Raum gestellt
dass er nach den Beschluss der
Staatsbürger von heute
die Volksrepubliken Don jetzt und Lorenz
anerkennen könnte geht ihr Satz wir
wissen was er tun auch für den Fall
einer solchen wenn man so viel kalten
Annexionen ist der Westen dann auch in
der Lage ähnlich entschlossen und
einvernehmlich zu reagieren ich glaube
dass sie da die Antwort
überinterpretieren aber werden wir ja
sehen für alle muss klar sein eine
Anerkennung wäre
ein Bruch der Minsker Vereinbarung
und ich habe ja heute in einer
Pressekonferenz mit jemanden gestanden
der daran so aufgefordert hat sich an
die münzkervereinbarung zu halten
taking my question
of you crane that the Nord Stream to
Pipeline project und muss
Probleme Americans and second about
using
today to make sure that will be Avant
[Musik]
Bundeskanzler der russische Präsident
wurde ja an einer Stelle eher
leidenschaftlich fast aggressiv als das
Senator angesprochen wurde und die Frage
des Übergangs Ukraine solle nicht
Mitglied werden auf eine bestimmte Zeit
sehen Sie nach den Gesprächen er hat ja
historisch argumentiert das ging so
nicht wir müssen das jetzt lösen sehen
sie da überhaupt eine ein Kompromiss
es gibt einen Fakt
und der fakt ist dass alle Beteiligten
wissen dass eine Mitgliedschaft der
Ukraine in der NATO nicht auf der
Tagesordnung steht und da müssen alle
ein Stück zurücktreten sich einmal klar
machen dass es ja nicht angehen kann das
ist eine möglicherweise militärische
Auseinandersetzung gibt vor dem
Hintergrund um eine Frage die gar nicht
auf der Tagesordnung steht und es ist
deshalb eine Frage der Führungsfähigkeit
aller Beteiligten in Russland in der
Ukraine in der NATO
dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht eine
absurde Situation erleben wie dann um so
etwas ginge das gar nicht Gegenstand des
Weltgeschehens der nächsten Zeit wäre
das muss uns gelingen und alle Gespräche
die ich führe gehen ein bisschen darauf
hin dass ich allen sage ihr wisst dass
alle ganz genau
jetzt ist es unsere Aufgabe ein Weg zu
finden der okay ist für alle auch im
Hinblick auf ihre eigenen Beschlusslagen
und Einsichten aber auch funktioniert
für den Rest das lässt sich nicht an
einem Computerprogramm aus einem Punkt
Computerprogramm heraus ablesen aber es
lässt sich politische arbeiten und das
ist die Aufgabe die wir haben
Bundeskanzler sie haben mehrfach betont
dass in das nochmal die Format neue
Hoffnung bringen könnte sie haben
Gesetze Gesetzesentwürfe von
ukrainischer Seite erwähnt was
Lokalwahlen angeht nun ist aber der
minzprozess ja auch deshalb ins Stocken
Stocken geraten weil die Sequenzierung
nicht geregelt ist die eine Seite will
Abzug schwerer Waffen und Truppen sofort
die andere Seite will Lokalwahlen und
Autonomiestatus relativ schnell woher
speist sich ihr Optimismus dass es
enormer die Format tatsächlich
Fortschritte gibt
der Respekt vor dem gerade
wiedergewählten Präsidenten der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gebietet zu
sagen dass alle sich einig sind dass der
Weg da raus
der Weg der da aus dieser Lage heraus
für die steinmeier-formel ist und die
regelt die Sequenzierung
ein Ziel ihres Besuchs war ja auch
besser zu verstehen was Putin eigentlich
will denn das fragen wir uns ja alle was
will er eigentlich was treibt ihn an was
will er mit diesem Truppen Aufmarsch und
geht es ihm nur
geht sie wirklich um die Ukraine oder um
was viel größeres
haben sie jetzt nach diesem doch langen
Gespräch den Eindruck dass sie
verstanden haben was er will und was
wäre das
die Zielsetzung Russlands und des
russischen Präsidenten sind ja
gesagt und autspucken
neben den Fragen die sich konkret um die
Ukraine drehen
geht es in der gesamteuropäischen Agenda
um die Frage des Verhältnisses zwischen
Russland und der NATO und wie sich die
Dinge weiterentwickeln werden um
Sicherheitsfragen und deshalb ist es ja
eine kluge Reaktion des
NATO-Bündnisses gewesen auf die
weitreichenden Anfragen die insoweit
formuliert worden sind auch konkret zu
antworten und Angebote zu machen denn
das ist ja in den Antworten wieder zu
finden die Bereitschaft nämlich über
Transparenz was militärische Bewegung
und Waffen betrifft und über
Rüstungskontrolle zu sprechen und
insoweit Fragen der Sicherheit auch zu
thematisieren damit wären wir ja zurück
in einem farbwasser in dem wir schon mal
ganz gut unterwegs waren und das glaube
ich
ist zwar nicht exakt
das was sich der russische Präsident
wünscht was sich in dieser NATO Antwort
findet aber es ist hat immerhin dazu
geführt dass wir jetzt ja gestern hören
durften und ich auch heute noch mal
verstanden habe sie heute auch noch mal
hören durften dass es ausreichende
Ansatzpunkt für die Fortsetzung von
Gesprächen ist und das zeigt ja dass es
sich lohnt an der Sache dran zu bleiben
und zu versuchen
voranzukommen trotz so weitreichender
unterschiedlicher Ausgangsposition
ich bedanke mich für Ihr Interesse wir
müssen weiter und leider draußen gesehen
ein Teil der Relegation Vergleich auch
über die Delegation entstanden
tschüss auf Wiedersehen
sobald die Pressekonferenz des
Bundeskanzlers nach seinem Treffen mit
dem russischen Präsidenten und wir
wollen da ein bisschen drüber sprechen
analysieren was aus den doch ein
bisschen dürren Worten jetzt gerade zu
lesen ist die der Bundeskanzler geäußert
hat Größe sehr herzlich Professor Thomas
Jäger Herr Jäger das ist ein bisschen
schwierig zu interpretieren wir haben
sehr kurze sehr knappe Antworten des
Bundeskanzlers gehört und eine sehr
allgemeine Darstellung was haben Sie
daraus gelesen
es ist ja so Herr Grund dass
Bundeskanzler Scholz jetzt nicht gerade
für blumige Ausführungen bekannt ist und
das hat er jetzt auch wieder gemacht das
hat auch zum Teil in der Pressekonferenz
mit Präsident Putin gemacht und
eigentlich kann man das was eben gesagt
wurde nur verstehen wenn man die
Pressekonferenz gehört hat und das
Ergebnis das Bundeskanzler Scholz aus
diesen Gesprächen formuliert hat nämlich
dass er sagte es gibt eigentlich drei
Wege auf denen es genügend Ansatzpunkte
für weitere Verhandlungen gibt die jetzt
gegangen werden müssen das erste ist die
Umsetzung dass der minzger Vereinbarung
das zweite ist eine politische
Verständigung über die
Osterweiterung der NATO ohne dass die
Prinzipien bei der Seiten verletzt
werden und das dritte ist die Frage von
Rüstungskontrolle Transparenz und
gegenseitigem Vertrauensaufbau und in
diese drei Wege ist sozusagen jetzt noch
mal Rück gefragt worden kritisch wie
soll das denn gelingen und alle drei
sind nun wirklich mit Hürden gepflastert
jetzt gibt es ja den schönen Satz wenn
man miteinander redet schießt man nicht
aufeinander so ein bisschen hörte sich
das in der Pressekonferenz vorher auch
an die er mit Wladimir Putin abgehalten
hat die zeigen wir gleich im Anschluss
an unser Gespräch
wir haben jetzt in diesen wenigen Worten
gehört dass es ein vertrauensvolles
Gespräch gegeben hat dass man im Dialog
ist und er hat auch darüber gesprochen
dass man lange miteinander geredet habe
und dass er das auch als ein positives
Zeichen ansieht
jetzt ist das alles diplomatensprache
aber sind wir ein klein bisschen auch in
den Gesprächen weiter nicht nur in dem
was ich offenbar vor der ukrainischen
Grenze abspielt nämlich ein kleiner
Truppenrückzug
das ist ganz schwer zu beurteilen und
steht wenn überhaupt am Anfang dazu muss
man wissen die zentralen Gespräche
werden Mama sagen leider nicht mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz geführt oder mit
Präsident macron sondern sie werden mit
Präsident beiden geführt das ist der
eigentliche Gesprächspartner den
Präsident Putin ernst nimmt und von dem
er sich garantieren erhofft für die
europäische Ordnung die dann den
russischen Interessen näher kommt ich
würde auch nicht vermuten dass relativ
rasch auf den drei Wegen die skizziert
habe mit Ergebnissen zu rechnen ist die
öffentlich gemacht werden denn am Ende
wird ein Paket geschnürt werden müssen
wo jede Seite im ein oder anderen Punkt
ein wenig zu schlucken hat nicht ganz
zufrieden sein wird aber man die
Paketlösung miteinander eben vereinbaren
kann und das erfordert dass viel hinter
verschlossener Tür gesprochen wird weil
erst alles vereinbart ist wenn alles
vereinbart ist und das hat die NATO das
hat die EU jetzt ja schon vorgemacht mit
dem Sanktionspaket über das viel
spekuliert wird das aber nicht auf dem
Tisch liegt hier gelingt es sozusagen
die Reihen geschlossen zu halten und das
wird auch für diese Verhandlungen
notwendig sein ja bei den Sanktionen
hatte der Bundeskanzler gesagt er sei
bereit zu Sanktionen auf die Frage eines
amerikanischen oder englischen Kollegen
aber er wolle auf jeden Fall versuchen
das zu verhindern auch das ist ja
eigentlich schon ein kleiner Schritt auf
Russland zu
ja das ist ja der Versuch der
unternommen wird über einen
Sanktionspaket Abschreckung aufzubauen
im Bundeskanzler Scholz ist ja mehrfach
mit dem Satz zu hören gewesen nun haben
alle verstanden um was es geht und man
mag sich das so vorstellen dass alle in
den Abgrund dieses Sanktionen geblickt
haben und gesehen haben welche sozialen
wirtschaftlichen ökologischen
politischen Kosten damit verbunden sind
und man eben auf allen Seiten denkt das
bringt uns nicht weiter im Gegenteil das
müssen wir in jedem Fall verhindern und
wenn dem so wäre dann hätte dieser
abschreckende Wirkung ihren Dienst getan
das Thema nordstream 2 das schwebt immer
mal wieder so als Symbol einer
politischen Diskussion über den
ost-west-dialog sind wir da ein kleines
Stück weiter gekommen
wenn Sie so wollen ja insofern als wir
wissen Bundeskanzler Scholz kann Nord
Stream 2 sagen da haben wir jetzt
wochenlang alle drauf gewartet und den
er hat es jetzt getan aber in der Sache
ist das wie es bleibt die russische
Seite betont den wirtschaftlichen Aspekt
betont die Sicherheit der
Energieversorgung für Europa die
Versorgung mit günstiger Energie die
langfristig sichergestellt ist und von
Seiten derer die jetzt da bemüht sind
ein russischer Gewaltanwendung
abzuschrecken wird eben darauf
hingewiesen dass dieses Projekt dann in
Gefahr ist und auch hier ist es so dass
es Sonderinteressen Deutschlands gibt
wie in anderen Fragen auch dass aber der
Bundeskanzler das immer wieder einbindet
in die allgemeine Reaktion der NATO der
Europäischen Union auf ein russisches
verhalten dass es eben zu verhindern
gilt
danke Jäger der vielleicht entscheidende
Satz des russischen Präsidenten lautete
sei bereit mit dem Westen in Fragen der
europäischen Sicherheit
zusammenzuarbeiten als symbolische Geste
hatte Bundeskanzler Scholz vor seinem
Treffen einen Kranz am Grab meines
unbekannten Soldaten niedergelegt und
auch der Rückzug von Teilen der
russischen Truppen an der Grenze zur
Ukraine geschah vor dem Treffen
vielleicht ein Zeichen einer Entspannung